[Music]
are you ready jazz is definitely very
intellectual in order to do it you
really have to dive into the harmony and
figure out what's going on and I think
there's a part of all of us that really
likes analyzing things
[Music]
it's a great outlet for people to really
be able to express themselves and do
things at a high level
[Music]
when you really nail something and get
it in the right spot and you know play
it exactly the right way it feels like
the universe's falling into place
[Music]
in the 1950s the tech Tony ins which was
a big band were performing dances they
were performing functions and class
leapin who was the music director at
that time thought we should try to
harness us somehow and make it better
and the number one person the Boston
scene at that time who was leading big
bands and was known as a consummate
teacher was her Pommery and I'm sure
what he probably said the herb is I want
the best then we can have get it going
in the spring of 1963 what he did with
the program here was to build it from
the ground up he illuminated the essence
of the students passion and he brought a
sense of professionalism and polish
the experience for me was just one of
wonder at how he managed a rehearsal
he had a wonderful way of working with
the students so that he could push them
and get maximum effort out of them but
at the same time be congenial he had
lots of little tricks that liven up you
know your melody lines when you're
playing and I've been passing these on
to people for decades now he said a real
good example for me he was he was a kind
straight-ahead down-to-earth
communicative helpful guy and made me
feel comfortable right away the
reputation that he built here for having
a great band I think it probably
attracted a lot of people it was called
the festival jazz ensemble because in
the early days they would go to various
jazz festivals he auditioned everybody
he was turning so many people away
decided to start like a feeder band the
concert jazz band was led by Everett
long stress and his focus was really to
teach us the fundamentals the big
difference from me with the MIT people
was when I told him something I only had
to tell him once and I couldn't do it
all the time because maybe they didn't
have the technique they do it all the
time but they understood it I was always
just really blown away not only by the
caliber of the band but the caliber of
the music it was always fresh it was
always new
[Music]
Jamshid sherif he was the the next one
right after her band in fact he had been
a student of herbes at Berkeley as well
as at MIT so he was essentially
handpicked by her to succeed him he was
younger and hipper and he brought a new
vibe to the band he was also a really
good writer some of the best music in
the bands library comes from Jam she
[Music]
I grew up with music that included rock
and funk and R&B so an even hip-hop so
all of those I felt were viable
rhythmic areas that the band could
explore
[Music]
in 1981 Mark Harvey joined the faculty
[Music]
and he really has been a central figure
to the jazz education experience at MIT
since that time
I've had a couple classes with him and
he's a genius and he's incredibly open
to to students new ideas
[Music]
that was a laboratory for composers
[Music]
Jim Odell had great success with
festivals and he brought wonderful
artists to engage and work with the
students including Phil woods and
Terence Blanchard and he also continued
having local and national jazz composers
innovative jazz composers write
expressly for the ensemble who's writing
who can I talk to about getting some
charts who can I get over here to work
with the band you know help me feed
their that you know the great appetite
that the fj's students had we've been
privileged and honored to be able to
interact with some of the greatest jazz
artists on the planet
legendary saxophonist Joe Lovano has
been an artist-in-residence a number of
times here at MIT
we were rehearsing one of his gnaw nets
and I had tried to as best I could do to
flee rehearse it close to the tempo that
he had recorded it out and he came in
and took it at a tempo that I had never
done it with with the students and I was
a little worried and unbelievably and he
was playing with them they rose to the
occasion and played way over their heads
[Music]
[Applause]
and it was amazing to seen it was just
another example of when you take a great
artist and you put them with students
for a passionate and have the ability to
rise they will rise
[Music]
[Applause]
we are rehearsing Chick Corea is from
forever
it's dedicated to her and Pomeroy and
the notion that he would write a piece
for MIT sent me out of orbit we thought
we would run it for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this Chick Corea piece is this beautiful
amalgam as' mess of melody and harmony
and rhythmic counterpoint it's taken a
while for it for the whole band to kind
of dig through this this heap of content
and start to gel it together of the
fridge
[Music]
[Music]
the students that perform music at MIT
and particularly jazz have such a deep
love of it that they just have to do it
it isn't a choice almost and I think MIT
is about passion it's about excellence
it's about stretching and I think any
innovation involves risk and jazz at MIT
is no exception
[Music]
it's definitely been something that's
made my time it and my teeth much more
enjoyable this is my meditation this is
my sit down time where I just get to be
in the moment and lose myself in the
music that I get to make with the people
around me it's just you know one of the
fondest memories I have of all of MIT by
far there's nothing to stop MIT from
being a leader in the jazz field for
another 50 years
hi this is Chick Corea I want to
congratulate all of you
I absolutely would like to congratulate
the MIT Jazz Band and program happy
birthday on 50 let's have 50 more at
least
congratulations to the festival jazz
ensemble for your 50th anniversary
you've lasted 50 years and it's only
getting better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations MIT jazz
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]